>> OTHERS ARE ALSO NO LONGER
CONTENT TO PLAY DEFENSE AND LET
THE CULTURAL BATTLE FACE.
>> WHAT HE HAS FOUND SO FAR HAS
BEEN NOTHING SHORT OF SHOCKING
AND HE JOINS ME NOW.
OKAY, LET'S BEGIN WITH SOMETHING
CALLED THE GENDER UNICORN.
>> STUDENTS ARE DIVIDED BY THE
OPPRESSOR, WHITE SUPREMACY
PYRAMID WHERE IF YOU BELIEVE
THAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE JUDGED BY
THE CONTENT OF THEIR CHARACTER
AND NOT THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN,
THAT THERE IS A POWER AND
PRIVILEGE IN THAT IS ULTIMATELY
ABOUT PARENTS HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO KNOW WHAT IS BEING TAUGHT IN
THE CLASSROOM.
>> THEY ARE HOPING THAT THEY CAN
GET TO SCHOOL AND WORK INCLUDING
THIS CHART.
UNDERSTANDING WHITE SUPREMACY.
THERE ARE A LIST OF THINGS THAT
ARE COVERT INCLUDING MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
AND POLICE MURDERING PEOPLE OF
COLOR, THAT IS TERRIFYING.
A CELEBRATION OF COLUMBUS DAY,
THAT'S TRIGGERING AND ACTUALLY
HAVING A BORDER.
AN DENIAL OF WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> THIS IS NUTS.
AND THAT CAME FROM THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MISSOURI IN
SPRINGFIELD, MISSOURI.
AND THAT WAS THE WHISTLEBLOWERS
COMING FORWARD.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, DURING THE
LOCKDOWN, THEY HEARD SOME
THINGS, THEY STARTED SHOWING UP
TO THE SCHOOL BOARD.
AND PARENTS NEED TO BE EMPOWERED
HE